you think America is a racist
country it's really hard to say no and
the reason why is because how racism has
been baked into so many of our
institutions I wouldn't say I think
there's a difference between saying I
feel like when people say is America a
racist country they're trying to add the
like the moral pejorative that it's like
well he thinks everyone is I'm America a
racist I think the way in which America
has been founded and operated like yeah
I think so today it's a racist country
oh yeah how many vages how many black
people have immigrated to the us over
the last 20 years I'm not sure about 3
million 2 million from Africa and a
million from the why would they come to
America if America was so raised a great
question that is a real great question
why do you think a lot of uh Muslim
people and a lot of people from the
Middle East still come to America
despite the fact that they were
literally profiled and targeted all
after a terrorist attack that really had
nothing to do with them in particular
yeah I don't remember any anti Asian
people come to the United States because
they fa very fair and Equitable
treatment that's why Asian Exclusion Act
Chinese Exclusion Act Asian bar Zone oh
well you're talking Japanese interment
camps what fair and Equitable treatment
are we talking about I I'm sorry I
thought we were talking about no I'm
saying I'm saying but you're saying why
would they come here they come here now
because obviously America's gotten
better no one argues that America hasn't
gotten better youever say if it's racist
if if America is actually hostile and
discriminatory against black people why
would three come in in 20 years well
first of all if we want to talk about
black people who immigrate here um often
times they come here with I'm not going
to say they come here with a
preconception about African-Americans
here but there's a demographical
difference between black people from
Africa who come here or from other
countries that come here and from
African-Americans that are actually
already here so a lot of them will
immigrate here from backgrounds of uh or
coming over for college or maybe they
already had a family member from a
wealthier background that is sending
them over for college that makes up a
lot of um especially a lot of work visas
will go to Nigerians and Indians because
they're working in Tech Industries and
stuff so it's not like these people are
and and because in general maybe
wherever they're coming from The
Economic Opportunity is probably better
in comparison to their country that
doesn't mean that they did a holistic
review of the race relations to the
United States and determine this country
isn't racist anymore I'm going to take
my chance over there they thought about
it before they immigrated I don't think
that it's you think they thought is it a
good idea to move across the world to
this evil racist country or you don't
think that that that that that passed
through their mind because a I think
that a country can have done evil racist
things in the past and you you're saying
today it's still racist I think it's
still racist yeah there you go yeah but
I don't think that that's a determining
factor in the so you're saying that if I
go there there's an increase likelihood
that I'll face discrimination cool but
if I go there I could also get a job
that's going to make me way more money
than over here even if I'm not being
discriminated against at all and in fact
we know that it's much uh you're much
more likely to get a job today for a big
company if you are identifying as a
person of color rather than as a white
person when yeah so okay so one of my
favorite studies in in sociology is when
they'll do application studies and
they'll um change up things like uh
maybe they'll provide a picture or
they'll do names right since
1985 there has not been any change in
the likelihood of getting a call back
for a job when you are black and
according to the sociological studies
according to Scientific consensus in
sociology this is now let me let me
raise another Prospect to you there was
a study just came out an analysis by
Bloomberg of 88 companies in the S&P 100
and it was it was over uh hiring
practice over the last few years because
the EEOC the equal employment
opportunity commission requires that big
companies with with more than 100
employees publish their work Workforce
demographics and over the last couple of
years 94% of people who have been hired
for a job for any of those companies
have been persons of color which is
pretty crazy because the country is 60%
white which means the only way they
could have arrived at that number is by
actively discriminating against against
white applicants and giving an advantage
to persons of I'm going to assume that I
can't even assume that your numbers are
100% correct CU are they you can Google
you're going to trust me that I'm going
to look it up and it's going to say that
94% of people hired for a job at these
few corporations not few it's 88 of the
top of the S&P 100 they're talking about
the biggest companies in America we're
talk we're saying that the the workforce
94% of the new hires yeah 94% of the new
hires how many new hires uh so cuz you
do understand that you could have a high
proportion of new hires be hired as
minorities and the overall makeup of the
company can still be white white we're
talking about the the policies in place
to talking about polic so 88 of the top
100 companies are attempting to increase
their diversity by hiring higher rates
of minorities and that means that the
racism's gone no it means that there is
new racism against white applicants if
only 6% means why would they need to why
why would they why would they need to
hire because we have we have de facto
and de racial discrimination and
employment against white people and to a
lesser degree against there's deao
racism you know what deao racism means
or deao discrimination yeah what does it
mean so deure racism would be as a
matter of explicit law and de facto
would be as a matter of implicit
practice and in the case of affirmative
action policies it's actually both well
actually no well deao would be as the
factor would be so the way I like to
think about it is when we had uh when we
look at Public Schools today there's
still a lot of defacto segregation left
over from the Jim Crow era because there
was no Ser because students
self-segregate yeah well because they
were put in a condition in which they
were already mostly segregated so you
can't there's even in mix schools I'm
saying there have been a lot of studies
on this and it's very odd because
because a lot of people want don't don't
like there to be self-segregation but it
happens yeah it will happen because of
different like cultural backgrounds and
everything but that is compounded with
the fact that there was never a real um
ability to fully desegregate public
schools and federal busing with the
National Guard what yeah and they and
they struck that down that was and it's
funny because Joe Biden back at it again
he was opposed to the uh the force
busting and everything along with a lot
of White America at the time and in 2007
chief justice Roberts they had the uh
Supreme Court decision where they
decided that attempts to desegregate
public schools by trying to by assigning
kids to schools based on like racial
background to try to like create a more
even mixture was unconstitutional so
even when we were trying it it gets
struck down and it gets struck down so
you still have not a properly addressed
situation which is going to if you're
spending all your life around people
around the same skin color of you then
when you get in the area even though
they're are more people of different
skin colors you're probably going to be
more comfortable with these people
around you and that's due to
circumstances that was not I'm not I'm
not disputing the fact that they that
there when I was talking about deao
segregation and the reason why is
because it's it's vestages that are left
over from policies that used to be in
place and not a serious act to to
correct them so how in the world is
hiring majority minority in recent years
corporations how is itao segregation
when the whole reason why they're
doing racial discrimination how is that
deao discrimination based off of the
when well unless when the vast majority
of the people at the corporation a still
be white and B the whole reason why
they're doing that is to correct for the
fact well you might say you might say
it's good discrimination which I suppose
is what you are saying but it just is
never thought I wouldn't say it's I
wouldn't say it is good or bad
discrimination cuz I
again assuming that the new hires are
are really 94% uh minority applicants um
I think that you could say that it's
it's a discrimination in a sense because
they're attempting to correct a
good discrimination but again I'm just
telling you it it it it undermines the
argument that you're making which is
that America today is racist against but
you do understand that if you but you do
understand that if okay who cuz first
let me say you do understand that even
if you did hire at a 60% clip for white
people because they're that's
proportionate right you say no but
you're saying you said it was crazy
because yeah I mean if you can take
white people stop being able to do any
job is 60% minority uh issue or is it
just because it's 94 when's the
threshold I don't I don't think that we
should have racial quotas for
hiring is it a it's also illegal UNC
so it's not a quot you can you can a
compelling State interest to do like
have diversity but there's not saying
you need to have X amount of black
people x amount of white people ex about
it that's not so as a as a matter of the
Ure policy we have affirmative action
which is a kind of racial discrimination
against white people into a lesser
degree agents and as a matter of de
facto hiring policy we have clear racial
discrimination because affirmative
action I'm sorry how is affirmative
action discrimination because you're
giving preference to One race over
another so
if let's say let's say that well again
and it's not even affirmative action
isn't even necessarily saying that you
need to choose one person over the other
it's Tak just giving an advantage no but
one race or another I wouldn't say that
because again we're talking about we're
talking about Advantage right how how is
it that an advantage is provided to a
group of people when they are given more
opportunity to actually succeed at a
level that's more proportional to what
they should have been doing otherwise so
if you put a bunch of institutional
barriers right and you say you cannot
come here because of race right you're
making an arbitrary decision or you're
cuz I'm saying back when College Chinese
Exclusion Act say yeah something like
something like that right if you then
proceed policies if you then put in
place policies to say okay these people
make up a certain subsect of our
population they live in the
society they should be participating and
we just decided that they're not going
to participate because of the color of
their skin then if we say all right
let's give more opportunity to them now
do you see the problem if you were to
then cry discrimination again because
then what is the alternative if we just
stop H having racial anything no
consideration of race right that's the
the the fallacy of colorblind law is
that what's the fallacy as in no law is
truly colorblind if you're talking about
so if we're saying okay we're not going
to have anything racial in it right
we're just going to hire um according to
proportion of the population which again
you're but no I'm not suggesting that
though I'm saying
we so not only by by factors of math or
you're going to have way more white
applicants you are neglecting the fact
that the reason why you have so few
minority applicants isn't just because
they're applying at a proportionate rate
and you're just saying no because you're
being discriminatory they aren't even
getting the tools to get there in the
first place because of policy that
affected them in the past talk why they
at a disadvantage why are they at a
disadvantage we can talk about black
people in particular we can talk about
um redlining and housing discrimination
we can talk about um the we can talk
about the after effects of slavery and
debt ponage that no one talks about I
noticed that uh that I never see you
guys like cover daily wire cover like
anything when it comes to the history of
black people that accurately un like
explains where we are at today because
the last cadow slave released in America
was actually in 1942 and that's not like
a that's not like a crackpot Theory
that's because um right after
segregation or right after slavery the
South didn't kind of just like give up
and be like oh you got our slaves our
economy is just going to go along now
they attempted to have a syst in which
they reimplemented it there are over 9
million slaves around going around today
not in the United States yeah that has
nothing to do with the what I'm talking
about so how does it not cuz we're not
talking about the historical or the
we're not talking about the context of
people who are Liv slavery conditions
around the world tell slavery is
practiced everywhere around the world
today what does that mean it means
forced servitude yeah no I'm no I'm not
saying what does slavery mean what does
it mean that is practiced in multiple
places and everywhere today does that
mean it's okay no it's very bad but what
I'm saying we're basically the only guys
that ever stopped it in all of human
history we in the west yeah that's funny
what do you mean by we in the west I
mean Europe and the uh countries that
came out of the European colonies are
the only part of civilization ever that
decided to end the practice of slavery
and they so for explicitly Christian
where do you think that slavery was most
popular well uh it was the Muslim
Pirates who were some of the largest
that's the when it comes to the trade of
the Barbary the Barbary slave trade no
yeah I'm talking about that uh the
Barbary Pirates that's in sheer
number-wise like compared to the
transatlantic slave trade with
African-Americans in particular it's a
bigger number yeah but I'm saying where
do you think it was most popular you're
taking that one instance today no I'm
talking about historically you're taking
that one instance of slave trading and
you're neglecting all the SL that going
on in Western countries if you count up
that number that's significantly than
the Barbary slaves I'm saying even like
today for instance in uh Africa is still
practiced there's a candidate for the
president of South Sudan who himself was
a slave and has been speaking out about
the problems of slavery all around the
world at the height of the transatlantic
slave trade there were more slaves who
were held in Africa than were shipped
over to the to the new world